all right
responsive dick
great are you familiar with a dick
I do actually it's been a while since I
had some spotted dick and the dick is
the uh
[Music]
hi I'm Rutha grin and this is snack Wars
USA versus UK it's a lot Bible
okay it's a pot Noodle and mac and
cheese on this brand yeah I think that's
like the iconic in there it is yeah yeah
um this is gonna be interesting actually
because I've just realized I actually
don't have a sense of taste
like inside things there I do have like
some sense of taste but okay these might
taste the same
because that's tiny bit I'll do more
than that
yeah Paul noodle it's good yeah
is that like the flavor you go for or it
is yeah what's the other flavor yeah
spice I can't really handle different
Fork great
all right
[Music]
yeah
it does kind of taste the same it's it's
good that's yeah I I would yeah I would
I would say pot noodle nice when's that
one playing for the UK yeah yeah cool
wow
oh great yeah yeah cool this is this is
trifle
do like try for do you yeah I do like
trifle yeah and this is a flurry yeah
McFlurry okay I'm just gonna go hold on
my beard
yeah that is good I I am a big fan of
ice cream I used to actually want to be
an ice cream man because my location
it's a good aspiration yeah I got the
van that was my first car I learned to
drive an ice cream there what song did
you play when you drove around
um I only had one song Green sleeves
kind of classic
yeah yeah a bit kind of like a medieval
yeah nice good yeah so trifle is a
three layered
dessert first layer
I think this is right but it feels wrong
now I'm gonna say out loud lady fingers
is that right and then jelly
or Jello custard and then
cream like Chantilly cream okay with
okay it's already got all the layers all
the layers yeah it's the lady fingers
the right to the ladyfingers oh that's a
big bear
foreign
with this
it like instantly takes me back to like
kids parties yeah a friend's house yeah
I'm gonna say
the ice cream is ice cream is good
but trifle is
the ladyfingers can you taste it tastes
what
oh it tastes yeah
no
that's a lot I don't know why that's
alarming for that all right
spotted dick great
and a cheesecake
I do actually it's been a while since I
had some spotted dick why is it called
that apparently in the 18th century dick
was an interchangeable word for pudding
really yeah really weird okay and the
dick is the
um
so the dick is the the recipe right okay
I didn't yeah okay I'll just go on
oh wow
there's a lot of it's a lot more raisins
than I remember don't you there's a real
concentration of race
um it doesn't look like the nicest one
in the world with cut maybe it needed
custom yeah sorry that's fine I mean I
think this is gonna win
so this is a New York cheesecake is it
what makes it New York really shipped it
from New York oh right yeah cool
yeah
hmm
yeah it's better
it's yeah it is better and actually
cheesecake is I don't think that's a
good name for it it's confusing cheese
feels like this should be something else
but sporty Dick's a great name not great
dessert cheesecake wins cheesecake wins
oh oh God okay right
shepherd's pie Shepherd's Pie's lab
with mashed potatoes on top
and yeah that's it isn't it that's it
yeah yeah it's quite simple I feel like
a trifle but it looks like layering yeah
yeah growing up
we we I was from one of five so we had
like a lot of mints was kind of what we
grew up on and I kind of developed a bit
of a phobia
minced beef because it was it was easy
because it was like five kids and it was
an easy way of feeding all of it
Bridges out OD'd on it
it is a deconstructed
maybe a quarter
yeah
it's good it's kind of great for
the winter it's kind of yeah I do like I
like it it's good but
this might be better yeah
yeah I mean I know exactly what this
tastes like
it's good and weirdly I can't taste this
this is like
this does penetrate my life is it the
gherkin coming through no I'm not leaked
no Americans okay it's just more fun
yeah
oh chocolate orange
absolutely classic and races
minutes okay
I love these this is gonna be
um
yeah you kind of slap it it's the
technique isn't it I think so yeah
that's what I've heard me
right
that's great it's such a good idea it's
such a good idea I read they did do they
did like a lemon as well but didn't with
lemon flavor chocolate it was a
chocolate lemon
but it just wasn't as good I'm not
surprised that didn't take off yeah
but yeah it's iconic it's just beautiful
there's anybody I like I do like these
but um
I don't know do you like peanut butter
yeah I do smooth or crunchy smooth
um the orange the orange
not the lemon not that oh my God
yeah I actually don't love that
the UK one wow
nice behind Shield it that looks [__]
awful goober
so this is what peanut butter mixed in
with damn jelly jelly sorry yeah yeah
not for me now
not I'd rather sit pins in me that's
giving me flash blacks to the toilet so
blasting oh yeah